meanwhile house lawmakers getting ready
they'll introduce two bipartisan bills
aimed at china today
one of them would allow victims families
to sue beijing over the covet outbreak
fox's contributor newt gingrich former
speaker of the house how you doing sir
and good morning to you
very curious to get your analysis of how
you see this plan out
let's begin there and then i'll pick up
on a few things after that
where is it going sure remember
look we're in a period where you have
common sense
and you have technicalities common sense
is
this was a manufactured virus it almost
certainly came out of wuhan
the burden ought to be on china the
chinese have lied to the world health
organization
they've lied to the planet they've now
closed down
the opportunity to have any kind of
serious investigation
this was originally called a china the
wuhan virus or the chinese virus
that's what it is and i think that it's
a sad story
that for over a year the western world
was was basically lied to by china and
accepted it
and people who said hey this is a
laboratory they were ridiculed and i
think now you begin to find out that the
weight of evidence
is overwhelming because in part because
technically
a disease which comes from an animal
into a human
evolves at a much slower rate this this
is
a very rapid i think deliberately
engineered disease
probably escaped uh by because of
club clumsiness or sloppiness uh
probably not a deliberate
effort but nonetheless china is
responsible for the death of millions
for economic crisis across the planet
for disrupting the entire world system
and the chinese ought to be held
accountable okay so
i don't disagree with anything you said
i
i
don't know if you're ever going to get
an honest answer out of the chinese
communist government no matter what
evidence you can prove there
so now now you've got this 90-day period
i don't know what you do during that
maybe you collect more evidence and
you put into a big report that makes it
obvious for the world to see
and perhaps you go get your allies japan
south korea australia
your nato allies and you put up a united
international front
to force beijing to admit it but even
then
the chinese communist party will not
make a public admission of this
so what is the level of pressure at that
point on president g
go ahead well what we ought to do i
think
is establish a 30 or 40 percent extra
tariff
on all chinese goods put that money into
a fund to pay off the families allow the
families to
to sue just like you would for any kind
of industrial problem
we've all seen the commercials if you
ever had x call the law firm
well we ought to say we're going to
charge the chinese
an extra tariff for being bad actors
and we're going to keep that tariff on
until we raise enough money
to pay off every american family the
rest of the world should take a note of
that
and they should do the same thing now
she would be faced with a real problem
because his export machine which keeps
his economy rolling
would be breaking and he would have a
real domestic problem
not just a bunch of words no last point
here david asher yesterday afternoon
with john roberts very intriguing stuff
here
on the intel community give that a
listen
i have a lot of confidence the
intelligence community at this stage i
think they'll find a lot
whether they'll say much is a different
matter we made a big effort under
secretary pompeo's leadership to
declassify critical information
i certainly hope and i know that
congress endorses this
uh bipartisanly that this administration
will do the same
we need to find out truth for the sake
of our future
and humanity i don't know if you saw the
interview it's very interesting where do
you see that going sir quickly
well i this administration wants to
somehow
find a way to be xi jinping's friend
not be his enemy and i i doubt very much
if president biden is going to allow the
american people to know what the
american intelligence community already
knows
i'd be very surprised wow um
i hope that's not the case sir thank you
for your time
we'll see you next week hopefully new
york thanks
dana hopefully